bueno esta es puerto resistencia a uno
de los puntos más emblemáticos del
estallido social
mayra fue parte de las protestas más
grandes de la historia reciente de
colombia en 2021 cali la tercera ciudad
del país quedó paralizada a tres meses
este es el extremar igualmente a un
compañero que fue
aparentemente víctima de una golpiza
policial y murió después de estar 15
días en coma en cuidados intensivos al
menos 44 jóvenes murieron la violencia
es recurrente en cali
también la desigualdad el 65% de jóvenes
vive en barrios pobres el paro les unió
queremos cambiar
pero este año mayra cambia la capucha
por las urnas
apostará por el candidato de izquierda
gustavo petro como 3 millones de jóvenes
votará por primera vez la hija de petró
sofía ha estado haciendo campaña a
partidista para incentivar el voto
[Música]
que nos ayude una persona como tú me los
ha entregado a sus 23 años carlos
combina tareas tiene una pequeña empresa
es practicante en una multinacional y
está convencido de votar por federico
gutiérrez el candidato de la derecha y
no necesitamos ideas locas populistas
imposibles para engañar a la gente
carlos es de un barrio acomodado de cali
su stock de carnes se vio afectado
durante las protestas cuando la ciudad
quedó aislada por el bloqueo de vías
aquí te traigo unas muestras y que la
abrimos aquí el fútbol
considera que en lugar de destruir hay
que incentivar la economía así
sucesivamente es una cadena que creo que
nace de las personas que emprenden a
querer a ser un mejor país siempre
firmes que no entren ya arriba pero en
colombia seis de cada diez jóvenes no
confían en las instituciones por lo que
para muchos la abstención es la opción
favorita es el caso de diego no va a ir
a votar el 29 de mayo me parece más
importante salir a entrenar trabajar de
mi oficio y pues ha sido mejor y sin
preocuparme de política o algo así una
nueva generación en la que cada uno a su
manera quiere dejar atrás los traumas de
la convulsa historia de colombia